do you know what this is next to me this
is an interactive 3d light sculpture
made up of over fifty four thousand
different points of light it's being
created right behind me in real-time by
the cuca cop 140 now you've probably
seen robot arms like this so
manufacturing cars or powering amusement
park rides but Microsoft is using this
to create this light sculpture for the
game Halo Reach so we have taken the
robot and we've put an LED on the robot
it's a red LED we're keen it in real
time we're driving a key that gives us
tracking data for the point that lets us
do a trail and also lets us birth the
the Stars the points of light and we're
doing that through a real-time
compositing system that's called touch
designer it can be thought of as
Photoshop in real-time or after effects
in real time if your compositor so you
can do visual effects on the fly in real
time and it's it's a very very exciting
technology every time the robot stops it
takes a grab we're continually caching
this accumulation this long exposure and
reapplying it over the video stream so
the robot is controlled by some custom
software that we've written and in C and
Python that communicates over protocol
called Ethernet IP to the robot cabinet
which is a refrigerator-sized computer
that then commands the servo motors to
go to certain coordinates so we were
sending it joint data for each of its
six axes so this is the Casey P 2 unit
and that is a means of programming the
cuca robot using this variable here I
can adjust the speed of the robot and I
can also hold down a few keys here and
jog each joint individually there is an
e-stop on here in case there's a issue
there's also a what is called a live man
switch because it sounds nicer than a
Deadman switch on the back so I need to
hold this in order to make it operate
there is a six axis space Mouse on the
on the cuca controller that's I'm told
allows you to drive the robot or I
cannot
figure out how to use it and the rumor
is that you have to be a German which is
the home country of Coca to actually be
able to operate the space mouth it would
spend most of life generally building
cars or welding or palletizing and we
think it's much happier working with us
on this project Halo fans are going to
be able to go to remember reach comm log
in using their Facebook login and and
plot their individual point of light
wherever they want to put it so the
robot arm will move where you want it to
and plot the point you only get the plot
once so choose your position carefully
and the light sculpture is going to be
finished by the time Halo Reach launches
on September 14th